bonjour je m'appelle Benjamin Biolay je
suis auteur compositeur interprète et
comédien et je vais réagir aux archives
de Lina
bonjour Benjamin Biolay on est très
content d'être ici à Rochefort à
l'occasion du festival sors jumelle
votre inspiration évidemment vous la
puisez dans votre vie mais vous
l'accusez aussi dans vos inspirations
dans des grands monuments de la chanson
française et on va commencer avec Henri
Salvador pour qui vous avez écrit un
titre très connu jardin d'hiver vous
avez même relancé sa carrière on
l'écoute
dérangez pas du tout faut faire tout ce
que vous voudrez parler tourner du
moment qu'on dit Angela on peut tous
permettre
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça le petit ange
le petit ange j'ai bien le petit ange
c'est celui qui me souffle mes chansons
quand je travaille quand je dors quand
je mange quand je parle avec vous il est
toujours là il est toujours là il est
toujours là des fois il me laisse tomber
j'attends que le petit temps je me
souffle un nez et s'il veut bien
peut-être que vous aurez la chance
d'avoir une chanson j'espère pour vous
[Musique]
le petit ange c'est déjà c'est une très
belle définition c'est une très belle
façon de parler de l'inspiration en plus
c'est c'était quelqu'un de plus
religieux qui qu'il en avait l'air dans
mon jardin d'hiver
donc son petit ange n'a pas quitté c'est
sûr parce que j'ai eu aussi l'occasion
de te réaliser l'album posthume d'Henri
qui s'appelle le temps de temps donc de
de produire les toutes dernières
chansons qu'il a fait dans sa vie il
était encore tellement inspiré c'était
bouleversant c'était donc non j'ai une
relation un peu élite et compliquée il
était un monsieur d'un certain âge en
plus qui avait
je pense avait vécu beaucoup de
situations très désagréable on va on va
on peut le mot qu'il faut je pense qu'il
a été beaucoup arnaqué dans sa vie donc
il est extrêmement méfiant vous aussi
vous avez un petit ange
peut-être un petit démon mais je vois
très bien de qui parle
alors on va parler maintenant d'un autre
artiste qui vous a également inspiré qui
parle lui d'inspiration ici il est
plutôt question de souffrance et de bons
sentiments
[Musique]
sur le dos des balais je suis vraiment
triste
créé il faut qu'on souffre un petit peu
sinon ça a pas vraiment de charme et en
même temps on a envie de donner des
bonnes choses le capitaine Nemo il va
quand même au fond des mers chercher des
trésors qui donnent à des peuples
qui souffrent de la tyrannie d'un
quelconque dictateur Hubert qui est
l'autre très grand musicien avec qui
j'ai collaboré j'ai beaucoup collaboré
avec lui c'est il allait chercher en lui
quelque chose de très très violent de
très très utile c'est un autodidacte
mais il employait des accords aussi
compliqués que ceux dans le réservador
qui a pris le jazz vous voyez il ne
supportait pas de faire d'eau face à
l'orée soit le reste il fallait toujours
qu'il se passe quelque chose dans sa
musique c'était un mélodie se fou donc
qui cherchait des mélodies incroyables
et il avait il avait besoin d'être ce
[Musique]
Julien Gréco je voudrais bien que nous
ayons plus de temps parce que je
voudrais bien savoir un tas de choses de
vous que vous n'avez jamais dit et je
crois que il y a beaucoup de gens comme
moi je suis comme les huîtres moi il
faut m'ouvrir c'est ce que je pense et
je pense que vous avez dit beaucoup de
choses qu'on a écrit beaucoup de choses
sur vous mais que le vrai mystère dont
on parle est ailleurs et qu'il n'est pas
là où on pense qu'il est il y a chez
vous un bonheur de chanter que
j'appellerai un bonheur inusable les
vagues nouvelles ou anciennes peuvent
bien passer c'est comme les cailloux
est-ce que vous êtes comme les huîtres
il faut vraiment faut me travailler au
corps il faut ouvrir au pied de biche et
elle représente quoi pour vous juger de
la Périco
une fée que j'ai eu la chance de côtoyer
une fée qui qui me chante à l'arrêt
depuis que je suis tout petit et que
ta maman la Providence a mis son chemin
et j'ai eu la chance de lui écrire des
chansons j'ai la chance passer du temps
avec elle j'ai eu la chance de l'avoir
telle qu'elle est installée
[Musique]
c'est vraiment ma Juliette dans la vie
elle était très pertinente elle pouvait
être très punk et très très amusante
alors on va écouter un extrait d'une de
vos chansons comment elle t'appelle que
vous chantez en 2020 sur le plateau de
France Télévisions à l'occasion de la
fête de la musique
j'ai posé le téléphone comme ça
je mesurais avoir entendu le gars
j'aurais dû te libérer avant que tu peux
nous avoir
j'ai fait le Bilan Carbone trois fois
parler de ta voix sur un ton cul d'être
femme tu te le sauras lever car tu peux
m'écoutes pas
comment elle s'appelle
la bière est comme ça
[Musique]
faut pas concentrer
à toucher le doigt
il faudrait qu'on apprenne
à vivre avec ça
comment est capable
la mère s'en vient
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle plaît autant
cette chanson aujourd'hui
dans sa vie j'exagère peut-être 3000 et
à la fin elle a 6 qui passe la tête on
sait pas pourquoi et celle-ci en fait
partie mais parce qu'elle est très
sincère aussi c'est vrai ce que vous
disiez je suis dans les interviews je ne
suis pas insensé mais je suis je
tendance à rien vouloir raconter parce
que j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
intéressant et j'aurais peur que ça ça
envoie des fausses puces sur mes
chansons en fait qui sont ma vraie façon
de m'exprimer mais quand j'écris je suis
d'une sincérité
[Musique]
totale même si le discours peut paraître
alambiqué mais c'est un peu cubiste
c'est vraiment ce que je pense c'est
vraiment ce que je ressens et
cette chanson elle me ressemble c'est
vrai alors on va écouter maintenant un
autre artiste que vous citez
régulièrement mais dans un autre
registre que le vôtre on écoute Charles
Trenet alors il faut les arroser tous
les jours les fleurs artificielles
et puis alors ça ça donne aux fleurs
naturelles l'envie de les copier parce
que vous savez que les fleurs
artificielles sont tout même plus belles
que les fleurs naturelles
de soleil c'est triste mais dès qu'il
pleut c'est très gai
parce que d'abord je suis un enfant
et finalement les enfants sont quand
même plus simple que les grandes
personnes c'est pas vrai on dit pas je
suis un éternel en France je crois que
je passerai de l'enfance au gâtisme sans
avoir été adulte jamais quelles sont les
avantages de la maturité je ne sais pas
puisque je suis pas mûr
les pirouettes toujours les pirouettes
je suis mur physiquement peut-être mais
moralement non
[Musique]
je le connais bien cet extrait à collier
d'amitié on voit qu'il fait un peu de la
muscu dans ce type de
bacs des trucs et c'est vrai jusqu'au
bout de sa vie la rosée c'est Florent en
plastique je suis en train c'est pas des
conneries du tout il a pas mis en scène
je sais pas il y a tout ce génie que
j'adore quoi que notre premier punk
vraiment quelque part Gainsbourg c'est
un bébé au niveau provocation et
embrouille médiatico judiciaire parce
que Charles Trenet c'est
notre époque mais je l'aime à la folie
viens plus près
mon amour
ton cœur contre mon cœur
il me fait pleurer j'écoute l'âme des
poètes j'écoute j'ai ta main tout ça je
pleure immédiatement longtemps longtemps
[Musique]
après
on disparu
dans les chansons j'aime pas ce côté
quand il est trop fou chantant là c'est
pas ce que je préfère moi j'aime les
chansons très introspectives mais là où
ils ne ment pas absolument non plus ce
qui est il sera passé de l'enfance au
gâtisme comme il l'a dit et encore un
gâtisme relatif parce que il buvait
encore sa bouteille de Cointreau par
jour par exemple c'est c'est une
montagne je suis en train de montagne
alors c'est intéressant parce que il
peut avoir aujourd'hui une image presque
un peu de réac avec des chansons comme
douce France etc il y a des gens qui qui
considèrent pas du tout comme un punk
vous savez quand c'est sorti de France
de parler de son pays quand il est sous
occupations nazis à ma à mon humble avis
on va parler de politique maintenant
vous êtes un artiste engagé
politiquement
voter et qui a été militant je pense
qu'il y a plein d'artistes comme ça mais
bon moi je l'ai dit parce que c'était
plus pratique et puis on vous a même vu
dans des meetings vous avez soutenu
[Musique]
de vos inspirations un grand monument
aussi et qui parle lui aussi de l'action
et de l'engagement
nous détruire les mythes de la culture
rock parce que les musiciens aussi bien
les vous les Stones ou les Beatles ont
tous parlé de politique de leur musique
mais ils ne font rien dans la réalité
nous faisons partie du fonds de
libération du rock maintenant
l'objectif c'est de libérer les
rois du rock'n'roll de même
le libérer pour qu'il fasse quelque
chose pour les gens on peut pas me
demander de réagir sur des propos d'un
mec défoncé à je sais pas quoi parce que
je le connais par cœur je les donne là
je peux vous dire que libérer les rois
du rock ça il est ça part d'une très
bonne intention comme toujours mais ça
devient vite hyper chaotique du fait de
son état de l'époque là où vraiment il y
a l'effort il était pas bien dans sa
peau à cette époque mais après sur le
militantisme c'est normal il vivait aux
États-Unis il était témoin vraiment de
la violence de
du Brevet Fédéral etc des républicains
il a soutenu le président Carter etc il
était impliqué il a soutengé la devise
plein de gens
et l'engagement c'est parfois un commode
est-ce que est-ce que vous ça vous a
joué des tours de vous engager
politiquement
j'imagine un petit peu ouais j'ai déjà
fait plus ou moins agressé mais je me
suis pas laissé faire donc c'est pas
fini en plus j'ai là mais mais non je
pense que dans mon public par exemple il
y a des gens de sympathisants de droite
par exemple je suis sûr j'ai jamais
demandé ce qui n'est pas mon cas par
exemple donc c'est pas parce qu'on est
on a une
une appartenance politique on a du
mépris pour pour les autres forcément
quoi j'aime pas ce côté
si tu n'es pas d'accord avec moi tu es
contre moi ou tu es un traître ou je
sais pas quoi et alors est-ce que ça
sert de faire des tribunes ou des
chansons contre le Front national est-ce
que c'est utile
non parce que ça les réveils
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas de la majeur mais
c'est de l'artisanat sérieux en général
je fais pas ça en un coup après je suis
parti un peu virale à l'époque des trucs
viraux ça n'existait pas donc je savais
pas aujourd'hui je ferais pas ça par
exemple mais je pense toujours ce que
j'avais dû écrire
menteur professionnel qui ne savent même
pas quel est le bouton pour qu'on freine
vous ignorez toute de la matière que
vous remuez mais quand ce n’éclabousse
non ne n'étais pas né amis entendu mais
à part les énerver étant donné envie de
me casser la gueule je pense pas que que
j'ai
que j'ai ramené quelqu'un entre
guillemets à la raison c'est une façon
de parler malheureusement je pense pas
qu'on soit utile mais heureusement
d'ailleurs
ça remet en question tout l'engagement
des artistes en politique on changera
jamais la donne on va vous montrer un
autre modèle
un autre modèle quoique vous en avez un
peu ras-le-bol qu'on vous parle à lui
mais bon Noël Lina on a trouvé ça
inévitable mais là on va vous montrer
une archive de lui qui a beaucoup été
diffusée dans les bêtisiers qui
faisaient rire mais qui aujourd'hui
provoque un certain malaise
[Musique]
vous êtes génial
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non
il dit que vous êtes très jolie non non
non non non non non
il a dit ça mais ça lui arrive de temps
en temps je peux pas vous traduire ce
qu'il a dit il a dit j'aimerais bien
vous offrir des fleurs pas du tout j'ai
dit j'aurais bien apaisé
[Musique]
j'imagine le réveil matin
cauchemardesque alors déjà pour la peau
[Musique]
il est normal vous imaginez quand il est
sous non non vous inquiétez pas Whitney
il est pas vraiment c'est son état
normal
j'imagine que personne n'avait dit lui
avait dit de se calmer sur le pastaga ce
soir là quoi et voilà il a il a
complètement perdu mais je sais qu'il
était vraiment
catastrophe et le lendemain
catastrophe et que dans les coulisses de
l'émission il y avait tout
[Musique]
la présidence de BMG et tout ça et tout
elle était jeune elle était mineur elle
était un drame et je pense c'est son
pire moment avec le moment où il parle
très mal à Catherine Ringer où je l'ai
détesté vous ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'être
ivre sur un plateau
[Musique]
alors on passe à un autre artiste
maintenant à qui vous avez dédié un
album hommage Alain Bashung qui nous
raconte comment il a réglé ses problèmes
identitaire la des peintres chinois qui
dessine le même tableau toute leur vie
et moi j'essaye de de mettre d'autres
couleurs mais ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que
je raconte autre chose
[Musique]
j'ai abandonné l'idée de de me poser ce
genre de questions me dire qui suis-je
mais plutôt que fais-je et je me définis
par rapport à ce que je fabrique
et je mets beaucoup de soins à essayer
de fabriquer quelque chose pour que j'en
suis j'en suis un peu fier et que alors
si en plus je peux donner du plaisir à
quelqu'un bah tant mieux ça c'est bien
c'est une décision que je trouve
parfaite
d'un artisan quoi vraiment
et qui avait pas envie de tourner en
rond et qui avait souvent envie de faire
le disque qui lui manquait tout court et
c'est un orfèvre c'est c'est vraiment
l'artisanat qui devient de dollars en
Bashung parce que c'est quelqu'un
vraiment vrai de très minutieux très
pointilleux et qui a une sainte horreur
devant lui
et qui avait cette habitude que je
trouve assez
prodigieuse de cacher son joujou dès
qu'il marche bien quoi
[Musique]
très très
populaire avec beaucoup de succès il
faisait exactement l'inverse
et les gens qui l'aimaient vraiment le
suivait puis les autres revenaient tous
les trois albums et puis c'était une
personnalité vous n'entendrez jamais
quelqu'un vous en dire du mal de tous
les gens qui l'ont connu c'est un d'une
gentillesse extraordinaire alors le
dernier personnage qu'on va regarder
évoquer un lieu cette fois un lieu qui
vous est cher vous vivez une partie de
l'année et vous participez même à un
festival allez on écoute que vers le sol
natal mon corps soit ramené dans un
sleeping du Paris Méditerranée
[Musique]
et regarde de cette
mon caveau de famille et là ce n'est pas
tout neuf vulgairement parlant il est
plein comme un œuf et d'ici
il ne risque de se faire retard et je ne
peux dire à ses bras vos jambes
poussez-vous donc un peu la faucheuse
sans quelque sorte
[Musique]
après vous allez aller manger au Copains
d'abord et puis à la mauvaise réputation
et puis
vous
mais il représente très bien il est
parti très jeune de 7 mais il représente
tellement ce terme c'est toi sa maman
italienne son père qui a un dur du
Sud-Ouest c'est un type qui connaissait
toutes les chansons de tout le monde par
cœur Georges Brassens c'est un vrai taré
de chanson c'est l'anti Alain Bashung
mais je l'aime autant et je la mets
autant et il a fait toute sa vie la même
chose
c'est le moment de choisir la personne
qui va vous poser la prochaine question
on vous laisse choisir entre Anne
Sinclair Thierry Ardisson Christine
Bravo et Jérôme Garcin
j'ai déjà eu droit dans la vraie vie
donc je vais pas le faire
Anne Sinclair ouais c'est original
vous cherchez à vous protéger
merci Benjamin Biolay merci beaucoup
[Musique]